John can you tell us a time when you
came close to quitting something or
actually did quit something and where
you were in that decision and if you
went back to it or not in writing yeah
it's interesting i've done that a couple
times in my career and the thing and is
funny we just had a guest at calarts I
co-run the guest artist workshop at
Keller and so we just had a guest who
spoke about this exact same thing
because he had a film that kind of got a
claim out of the out of the film
festival and he got you know a big
company interested in him and started
development deal and he spent five years
of his life in that in development hell
you know but he was making money and he
had Hollywood interested in him but
nothing was happening and similarly I
had and so and then he said why am I
doing this I'm going to switch my career
path and I'm going to start doing this
other thing which became very successful
and so I think it's important in all the
arts but especially in in film is to be
very cognizant if you're doing something
that is supposed to be achieving another
end and you know you get caught up it in
it so that that becomes your life and
you're not really achieving what you're
trying to achieve so the to give you a
couple concrete and answers in in
relationship to my career like very
early on well it's happened a lot like I
came out of film school and I produced
my wife's first feature and I very early
on realized you know I'm very good at
producing but I want to direct so it was
just like people came to me afterwards
inside dub you want to produce stuff
blah blah blah it's like no I'll suffer
but I want to direct so and after you
know I started doing music videos i
started with it did the nine snails
happiness in slavery music video so i
got launched into this music video world
and i did a bunch of music videos like
20 to 30 music videos and the music
video world was kind of tightening at
the time like budgets were coming down
and fewer fewer things were being made
by the same token they were still going
out to multiple directors and having all
these directors like 52 unfortunately
ten directors at times right treatments
for these music videos so you ended up
writing all these scripts and i realized
that after a year like i've written
two scripts worth of ideas for these
music videos and I've maybe gotten five
of them but there's all this work that
I've done and you end up on these
hamster wheels in Hollywood where people
get you to do work that isn't really
that always has the promise of something
but then doesn't really but it's always
dependent on someone else's decision and
so I was funny my editor at the time who
is cutting my music videos is look I
know you know you guys all want to make
features and you know and the only way
I've seen it done successfully is when
you guys jump off this hamster wheel and
you just stop and cold turkey and stop
doing music videos it's write a script
and get it made and so that's what I
actually did I just stopped doing music
videos and I wrote Cleopatra second
husband and got it made and you know
that was my that was one of my first two
features I made to I ended up at the
saml taneously after I did that then the
dead Olivia circuitry documentary
project came to me and I ended up making
both of those simultaneously and then
release those and then which leads me to
my hamster a second hamster wheel story
which is okay so I make these two
features that get released you know
theatrically not huge releases but they
get you know a lot of film festivals and
they get released theatrically and and
so out of that I start you know it was a
time in Hollywood this is like in
2010-11 when there were still spec
scripts being bought by up and comers
and so I actually sold to spec scripts
right out of the game my first two
pitches I sold and which is you know
decent money you know it was decent and
so but the problem is is that as I was
doing this the spec market was also
tightening and so I kept on developing
pitches and going out on pitches it
became a very similar hamster wheel to
the music video world and and then I
realized well this isn't going actually
the last this is what led me to vomit
because the one of the last things I
pitched on was a duck it was a feature
film about graffiti writers and in order
to to and I didn't know anything about
graffiti at the time and in order to
have some sort of understanding of
graffiti i started doing interviews you
know with friends that friend set me up
in with in New York of graffiti writers
and I
I got hooked on the actual documentation
and what was going on and less and less
interested in the script and then the
script didn't happen it was at Fox and
Fox ultimately said oh we don't want to
have anything to do with graffiti like
why are we making this film forget it
and and then I just said I'm
gonna make the documentary blood kind of
simultaneously and that was you know
because at the time it was like I'd
spent you know I think I finished we
finished the releases of better living
through circuitry and Cleopatra second
husband around 2001-2002 thousand eleven
no 2001 2002 and so I bid on this kind
of spec hamster wheel for like a couple
years by that so it's around 2004 and I
just said it's time to make another film
and it's just like in its like you know
this world isn't working and so
I'll do it myself like which is
basically most things that have kind of
like if you if I look back on it most
things that have come to me in my life
has have always been by me doing it
myself you know or taking the initiative
and trying to get and then bringing
other people on board you know and not
and of course it's not doing it myself
totally it's like the class is you know
di WL which I don't like either but you
know it's basically you know but it is
kind of like your own initiative and
saying it I'm gonna do it you know
and that's where you know and that's
even how I started my career's like
working in punk rock and you know and
even the early distribution stuff I was
doing with the punk rock videos that we
made it's like I saw well no one is
showing these like the knees should be
shown you know no one's showing these in
Europe and like you know so eyes
just got on the phone you know with a
SAP card and out of a phone booth at
three in the morning and just our calls
places and you know throughout my life
that's pretty much what you know it's in
which is you know it's pretty obvious
like from philosophically where I come
from and again I think it to me I'll
just repeat because I get called this
DIY guy which in a sense is true because
of the attitude but I don't feel that
dude purge flow makers to
not do it yourself it's like do it with
others but it's I think direct
distribution is like a much more apt you
know title that you're going direct to
your fans or direct to consumers as
opposed to going through larger
companies and I do believe in hybrid
distribution as well because I don't
think that everything the best way is
everything is you directly i think that
other companies if you can get certain
other reputable companies involved in
your releases like I've done with new
video a couple times and and CRM and
other companies they gravitas that I've
worked with that you can take advantage
of their resources and they can help
your release ok you get long answers to
questions from me so I think that's does
that answer your question ok
Oh